anyway anyhow any any who's alby's
what's been going on it's been theirs in
a week it's been a week you know what I
want to bring up right away
what is the editing conversation that we
had oh yeah because we had that
conversation about like having an editor
and how cool it is and how funny the
video is gonna be and everyone and how
and how like you know it's still our
style but it's someone else you know
doing the bulk of the work and all this
stuff and how great I felt and then I
posted that video and have never
received more negative feedback on a
video then then that video
I think people went harder on us for
that and the girl who punched her dog is
it like like the reaction of that was
like weak like we killed a baby on
camera I was like believe it I could not
believe it because the worst part was I
watched and I loved it I thought it was
hilarious I loved the pacing yeah
because I guess yeah and and yes I watch
ourselves in a different way
yeah of course that mean of course but
it was just like and never mind that no
as a person either yeah yeah people were
tweeting at hey just one write to them
and we're like you [ __ ] yeah you made
a mistake and I don't know if you've
thought about ending your [ __ ] but you
should yeah you way overdid it buddy
I don't mean do you know I don't mean to
get myself involved in this but I'm
going to you overdid it and you [ __ ]
up and yeah have you considered suicide
at all because I'm like it was crazy
yeah so bad for the kid cuz he worked
really hard on that video yeah and but
that being said I do understand I now I
understand and it that was a learning
experience for me I guess like reading
the comment being like damn people are
really it's really jarring for people to
see this drastic of a switch in style
and I I get it yeah well really get it
although people expect something from
that series they expect something from
the way I've been editing it forever so
all of a sudden for it to be totally
changed yeah it's funny cuz around 70%
of the comments were probably negative
and then 30% were people being like I
really liked it you like the new style
yeah
so I mean I understand and now we get it
yeah yeah now moving forward Noah's
still gonna be editing for us but you
know obviously it's we'll just change
the pacing change the pacing and the
funniest thing about the whole thing is
that I so I had
new video idea for the watermelon [ __ ]
now I'm gonna edit this one all myself
yo okay just so I can reset things back
to zero and then we'll ease into editors
and stuff like that okay so I edited it
everything myself went super easy I
barely I mean you know I spent a long
time on it but you know in terms of the
timeline it wasn't that crazy wasn't
crazy chops and all this [ __ ] I posted
it and I get like a hundred comments
probably being like wow you're still
using that editor you gotta fire that
guy [ __ ] what do you want it's me it's
me just look at the other craft videos
it's edited exactly the same Wow this is
even worse than the last one yeah who
[ __ ] editor this piece of [ __ ] know
it so let's you know we we understand we
understand and we're not trying to I'm
not trying to upset anybody with the
[ __ ] cuts we we are this this is you
know we are working hard and steadfast
to a solution no I'm joking yeah what we
we understand everybody it's not it says
it's not as bad as any of us make it
seem to be what you know me like it's
just you know just to edit no one like
that it that's fine like the content
still there you know what I'm saying
yeah yeah I didn't trip me too hard yeah
we just it was a it was shocking cuz I
was like I watched it I was like it's
éclairs everyone's gonna love this and I
posted it and it's just weird when
you're 100% certain on something oh yeah
then it goes the complete opposite way
they're like oh oops I don't know
anything anymore I don't know what how
to make people happy I don't even know
why I'm making videos I'm gonna retire
yeah and I'm gonna sell insurance and
said it's awesome when you know you work
so hard mentally to reassure yourself
with what you're doing and it all just
comes crumbling down I don't want I
don't want to come across like [ __ ]
I'm not speaking for you but I don't
want it to seem like we're [ __ ]
arrogant or something about the
situation like no we totally I don't
think that that's yeah I don't think
that's how we're coming across I just
think maybe I am but I mean nah I mean
people we understand you you wanted a
certain way and we want to we respect
that 100 percent so we don't want to so
it's back to regular schedule probe
yeah I mean no was cutting something for
me now and like he definitely like - all
of the [ __ ] super negative like you
did a [ __ ] job comments like he
understands like the other pacing was
way too fast and like this this new cut
he gave me is like very like very bang
on you know it's a he's figuring it out
and kind of just like he he's
approaching it differently and like it
it it is kind of I think maybe we're a
little bit ambitious to sort of like
just hand that off being like it's gonna
be fine you know I'm saying like I guess
yeah I think that there might have been
a little bit of ambitious just assuming
that people wouldn't notice cuz I mean
at the end of the day that that's why
anyone has watched what we've done is
because or what you've done or whatever
is cuz how you tailored it you know I'm
J and so it is gonna be different if
it's not you all the way through so I
felt I felt so bad because I hit him up
and I'm like hey I got this footage one
second sorry yo what's up cool I'll just
go [ __ ] myself
just go [ __ ] myself it's all good I'll
talk to you I'll talk to you guys yeah
yeah sorry about that they didn't tell
me so you're all good okay probably like
1:30 all right for sure sorry let's cut
that out
alright so continue so I hit him up a
night and I say hey like you know we
just shot this got the footage I'm gonna
start working on the next one so you
know can you edit this and I'm all
excited and he's all excited and [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] he's sending me cuts I'm like
yes this is great right this is great
next you know he's like first three
minutes [ __ ] great sends me the next
four minutes [ __ ] great blah blah
blah it's all positive it's all positive
I'm like great it's going live posted as
a premiere didn't even get to monetize
all and the Commons start rolling in and
he's like dammit you text me now I'm
really getting torn apart in these
comments and I'm like I haven't checked
him yet so I go and I'm reading some of
them and I'm like
they are a little bit native but you
know it's a little bit change in pace so
like it'll-it'll whatever i'm sure
people will come around
another hour rolls by roll they're just
getting worse
it's connect and the ones at the top the
most up butter ones are like fire you're
at it oh my god no I'm like dude I'm
really sorry I think this is my fault
like I should have been more sensitive
to the fact that that this is such a big
change in style it's my fault
going forward will like work more
closely about like goals for that and
some like that yes I felt bad
especially after the tweets of people
like why is supported understand it fire
your editor like you [ __ ] ain't
ever made a mistake like you never
showed up late to work or [ __ ] up your
own your homework or skip the lecture
like nobody's went to 1,000 like not
even a hundred just like fire him and
his career like what the [ __ ] you think
[ __ ] like oh my god I did not
understand it it's not [ __ ] wonnered
like zero or ones not but not binary
[ __ ] like goddamn it's granular
Jesus Christ oh no I fell for Noah just
cuz you know he was just here just
trying to do the job he's really funny
man I watched on here some sketch on his
Twitter that he made of like himself
playing two different characters yes
funny so good I feel like I was just
freestyling yeah edited together super
funny the way he cuts that [ __ ] is so
funny so good yeah yeah anyone is
doubting Noah's ability to cut
[ __ ] go look at the Midwest vlog
go look at that bit he can cut man you
can so shout-out to him so do you know
if you're watching this yeah and
honestly we know we at the end of the
day we do appreciate that we can't have
a two-way conversation about this [ __ ]
and ultimately we want you guys to enjoy
[Music]